I say looking at the next 100 years that
there are two trends in the world today
the first trend is toward what we call a
type one civilization a planetary
civilization a civilization that
resembles something out of Buck Rogers
or Flash Gordon a type two civilization
is stellar they consume so much energy
they can play with stars that's for
example the Federation of Planets is
Star Trek Star Trek would represent the
typical type to civilization then we
have type 3 which is galactic like the
Borg or Independence Day or the Empire
of The Empire Strikes Back that is a
type 3 civilization which is truly
galactic now by the time you reach type
2 you are immortal nothing known to
science can destroy a type two
civilization comets meteors earthquakes
even a supernova a type two civilization
would be able to survive even a
supernova the danger is the transition
between type zero and type one and
that's where we are today we are a type
0 civilization we get our energy from
dead plants oil and coal but if you get
a calculator you can calculate when we
will attain type 1 status the answer is
in about a hundred years we will become
planetary we'll be able to harness all
the energy output of the planet earth
will play with the weather earthquakes
volcanoes anything planetary we will
play with the danger period is now
because we still have the savagery we
still have all the passions we have all
the sectarian fundamentalist ideas
circulating around but we also have
nuclear weapons we have chemical
biological weapons capable of wiping out
life on Earth so I see two trends in the
world today the first trend is toward a
multicultural scientific tolerant
society and everywhere I go I see
aspects of that birth for example what
is the internet many people have written
about the Internet
billions and billions of words written
about the internet but to me as a
physicist the Internet is the beginning
of a type one telephone system a
planetary telephone system so we're
privileged to be alive to witness the
birth of type 1 technology a planetary
telephone system what is English English
is the beginning of a type 1 language
everywhere I go around the earth people
speak English because that's the lingua
franca of science technology business
they all speak English it is the number
one second language on the planet Earth
and what is the European Union the
European Union is the beginning of a
type-1 economy and how come these
European countries which have
slaughtered each other ever since the
ice melted 10,000 years ago how come
they have banded together put aside
their differences to create the European
Union well to compete with us and who
are we we are NAFTA so we're beginning
to see the beginning of a type-1 economy
as well then we're beginning to see the
beginning of a type-1 culture everywhere
I go you turn on the radio what do you
hear rock and roll you hear rap music
you hear youth music Youth music is now
planetary knows no boundaries around the
planet Earth everywhere I go I see
high-fashion Chanel Gucci Bags they were
producing the birth of a planetary
fashion also sports take a look at the
Olympics take a look at soccer we're
seeing the beginning of a tribal
initiation rite called sports being
turned into a planetary initiation rite
that unifies the entire planet so
whenever I open the newspaper every
headline I see in the newspaper points
to the birth pangs of a type one
civilization information however every
time I open the newspaper I also see the
opposite trend as well what is terrorism
terrorism in some sense is a reaction
against the creation of a type one
civilization
now most terrorists cannot articulate
this they don't even know what the hell
talking about but what they're reacting
to is not modernism with the reacting to
is the fact that we're headed toward a
multicultural tolerant scientific
society and that's what they don't want
they don't want science they want a
theocracy
they don't want multiculturalism they
want mono culturalism so instinctively
they don't like the the march toward a
type one civilization
now which tendency will win I don't know
but I hope that we emerge as a type one
civilization now in outer space we look
for signs full of intelligent life in
outer space so far we find none
civilizations like type 1 should be
commonplace in the galaxy
some people assume therefore that type 0
civilizations are rather common but only
a few of them make it to type 1 because
that society for the first time in its
history has the ability to commit
planetary suicide so maybe that's the
reason why we don't see aliens in outer
space maybe they never made it maybe one
day when we have starships and visit
them we'll see atmospheres that are
irradiated because they had a nuclear
war atmospheres too hot to sustain life
because they had a runaway greenhouse
effect maybe when we go in out of space
we'll see the corpses of type 1
civilizations that never quite made it
who knows